remember when it was bad for local media
to convey coordinated messages over the
airwaves you know like when Sinclair
media asked local anchors at their
stations to read the same promo script
to describe their newscasts
they were derided by legacy media as
Orwellian Soviet style propaganda so it
created local Stepford Wives oh the
outrage you get the idea there what's
going on all these anchors and all these
markets required to read this script
it's a attacking fake news if you are
centralizing a political message to
however many more than 200 stations I
think it'll be if they get the FCC
approval for this to two hundred
stations you have one of the great
political messaging machines in the
world so it was an abuse of the media
for Sinclair to air these homogenized
promos and local markets but when the
legacy media coordinated is across local
markets it's apparently no problem at
all tomorrow
over 350 papers organized by the Boston
Globe will print coordinated editorials
to denounce the president for his fake
news comments and media trash talk
sounds like one of the great political
messaging machines in the entire world
if he asked me Margery Pritchard at the
Boston Globe told CNN quote we have some
big newspapers but the majority are from
smaller markets all enthusiastic about
standing up to Trump's assault on
journalism what we are witnessing is the
full-on politicization of the media as
Steve Annan once said the media have
become the opposition party and that's a
pity I think it's ever since their
disastrous mistreating of the electorate
in 2016 they have obsessively worked to
prove themselves right in other words on
just about every issue they paint the
most insidious portrait possible of the
president in order that later on they
can say see we told you so we were right
I think it's also utterly predictable
the better the economy
gets the more confident the American
people are about their future the more
frantic that never Trump press becomes
it's a perverse inverse relationship and
I've noticed something else the more
popular Trump becomes among African
Americans his numbers are as high as 36
percent according to Rasmussen the more
desperate the scribblers are to tar him
as racist and of course they throw in
xenophobic and misogynist for good
measure
so rather than cover how American lives
are being transformed due to a booming
economy and record-breaking employment
figures the media focus on self created
controversies like fabricated dossier
claims what was in the dossier was
spelled out detailed allegation that
there was a a mutual operation underway
here that there was collaboration and
coordination between the Trump campaign
and the Russians a day that began with
clips of James Comey former FBI director
all over television telling ABC News
that he cannot rule out that the
infamous pink tape mentioned in the
steel dossier is real me the P tape or
whatever has credibility listen that is
exactly what Muller is looking at one of
the things and so we'll find out false
and one of my personal faves that media
obsessed on the breathless Melania is mi
a speculation one thing that the
president the White House have been
quite quiet about is Melania Trump and
her status staying behind at the White
House it seems First Lady Melania Trump
a public hasn't seen her in 23 days many
wondering where she might be
if the first lady or the person who's
standing in for first lady disappears
you want to know where she is the first
lady was recovering from fairly serious
surgery by the way a lot of these
journalists take off two weeks for what
a colonoscopy and now we're caught up in
the armor OSA obsession
it's a wall-to-wall coverage of a woman
lacking credibility pushing specious
claims complete with surreptitiously
recorded audio snippets
oh dear Donald Trump utter the n-word on
our porting in any context we already
know that this president seems immune
from even the broadest standards of
decency we've had in the common in the
past another tape wouldn't change
anything people are at least prepared to
believe a lot of the things that she's
saying about him and at least a couple
of things have looked like they might be
true based on some of these tape a
couple of things look like they might be
true based on Rosa's stream of charges
have been refuted by nearly every party
she quotes in her book Frank Luntz
Katrina Pierson and Lynn Patton who is
her closest confidant at the White House
was on our show last night they all
dispute her claims and the president
says the producer of The Apprentice Mark
Burnett also denies that there's any
tape but still the media happily gives
Omarosa hours and hours and hours of
airtime I think in their warped thinking
the woman America considers to be the
ultimate mean girl helps advance the
narrative for the media that Trump's a
racist but once again I think the media
are mistreating the American people
here's the latest data according to an
NPR PBS Newshour Marist Poll that's a
mouthful 71% of Americans have not very
much or no confidence at all in the
media compared to just 25% Oh have a
great deal of confidence or quite a lot
but the amazing thing is the meaning you
don't seem to care about what the
consumers of news are shouting at them
so if the ratings and readership are
down whatever we have a mission that's
to get Trump most of completely
abandoned the idea of objectivity and
are now essentially operating as
full-time members of the resistance so
now that we've established all that what
lessons can the White House take from
all this I realize it's tempting to
swing at every pitch but let's be real
here as Trump proved in the election the
media just aren't that influential
anymore
so the president needn't feel like he
has to respond to their every utterance
regardless of how vicious it is combined
the media's waning irrelevance with the
Democrats invisible
legenda and the president I think has a
pretty sweet opportunity to actually
expand his base before November now a
lot of people are shaking their head how
can that be
I know it he'll be on the stump and
critical races before November but I
think he should also take the time to
visit places that Republicans have often
ignored mr. president your agenda is
working so sell it everywhere and listen
to the people who are being fed a load
of malarkey about what's in your heart
and mind and show them what's really in
your heart in mind and yes that means
doing events exclusively for African
American Americans and Latinos including
in distressed communities places like
Chicago where Democratic leaders have
failed abysmally show them a better
alternative and celebrate the gains
you've already won for them and all
Americans too many Republicans never
understand that you often win respect
for just showing up but of course don't
expect the editorial writers to give you
any credit for any outreach like that
but in a way who cares no one's reading
them anyways and that's the angle